the jurgen experience that's what's
crazy about this it's so
there's so many variables in terms of
like how people how people are affected
by it and what goes wrong
because there are so many variables yes
there's your your your genetics there's
your immune system like
how is your immune system shaped what
your there's your diet that's included
in it your vitamin d status your
you know there's there's you know the
other interesting thing and
and there's been no studies with sarge
cove too but there have been influenza
studies
showing that viral dose it's really
interesting studies that have been done
where
i don't know who volunteers for these
studies but like sign me up to get
influenza i want to be
right let's give you anyway they somehow
get
healthy people to to do that and there's
been these studies where um
people are like controlling the
intranasal like they'll give them
um various titers of influenza virus and
they try
the point of the study is to figure out
what viral dose and they have like some
measurement like in v
in tissue culture number or whatever and
they found like to make people have
symptoms right
and they found with influenza i forgot
which a
or something i think one of the strains
it was like they could do a certain dose
like 10 to the seven
in tissue culture or whatever units
where
70 of the people would get like symptoms
ranging from fever
you know cough and all the influenza you
know flu
symptoms but then when they went down to
from 10 to the seven
let's say they went down to 10 to the
five only like 10 percent of people were
getting
sometimes so like it's kind of
interesting that
viral dose at least with influenza and
there's actually been some
other studies i think measles also that
it is
it is a thing not something that you
want to like go and experiment with
yourself
but um you know that's another
possibility right
for sure when you hear about nurses yes
they're getting
way more sick right because they're i
mean that could be one reason right
right their
their actual job is to be around
infected people and
they're intubating these people and
they're they're they're they're doing it
like oh yeah they're getting it right in
their faces right with some of them they
have poor ppe especially in the
beginning when
you're seeing these people that were
like using makeshift masks and
trying to it's horrible yeah they're i
think with the masks you know
for for people i mean reopening the
economy and you know some places have
more been more
successful um you know like you know
even even like japan and stuff where
you know the wearing the mask like the
cloth mask doesn't do much to
prevent you from breathing in maybe a
respiratory droplet or something or
aerosol
right that you know but but it will
prevent you from spreading it
you know to so to to a certain degree
like i get that people don't want to
wear masks like it
sucks like who that you know who wants
to wear a mask but
maybe to open up the economy again like
now
maybe like everyone could wear a mask if
they're going to be inside around a
bunch of people
grocery stores than keeping the economy
closed better than keeping the economy
closed
i'll be willing to do it it's not going
to be forever you know why it's not
going to be forever
because we're going to figure this stuff
out we are like it's already we're
already finding repurposed therapeutics
the monoclonal antibodies people are
working on that that's going to be
coming soon
the monoclonal antibodies remember you
were talking about the llama so the
whole point of that is that they're
identifying antibodies that can
neutralize the virus
and they're going to grow them and
manufacture them and give them to people
it'll help treat eventually they'll
identify one that you know works
what kind of a timeline do you think
they have for something like this oh i
think that i think things are gonna i
mean i think that these therapeutics can
start
the monocle so like rem deserver has
already been identified and they may
start to identify other ones like the
pancreatic
pancreatitis drug in japan kamastat
something
um there's the pepcid i mean there's a
lot of different repurposing drugs that
are being investigated
you know and i think over the next
couple of months and then regeneron's
already you know
doing one of these monoclonal antibodies
i think in the next couple of months
we'll we'll have more therapeutics than
we have right now
that that'll that'll make things less
scary people will be
less scared of getting sick because
they'll have you know they'll have a
better idea of oh we have some more
you know things that can therapeutically
treat this you know successfully
hopefully people are going to start
looking at the vitamin d i really like
like
i really hope that if not just i hope
people are going to
you know take their vitamin d or ask
their doctor to take it you know
um but yeah i think that in a couple
months so like can you wear a mask for a
couple of months and like
here's why it's not going to work to
just have the people that are vulnerable
wear the mask
because the cloth mask isn't going to
prevent them from getting
you know the aerosolized droplets if
you're spreading it in asymptomatic
which
that that's been shown that you if you
are asymptomatic that cdc study i
mentioned a while ago about how
pre-symptomatic versus asymptomatic
after a week when they came back to
measure
the people again they found that out of
the 13 10 of them actually did get
symptoms
the other three that were asymptomatic
had as much they were they had were
spreading um sorry shedding as much
virus uh that
could make them you know basically
contagious and you know be
basically able to transmit so strange so
um
the point is that i think that i know
people don't want to wear masks
and i have i have family members that
like think it's like infringing their
freedom you know and like it it does
suck and i know people are worried i
mean the thing is like also children i
don't know how to tackle that
issue because it's really hard that's
that seems a little more difficult
but like adults you know you know i
think that if you're working you want to
open your
your restaurant back up your you know
like
masks i think that that seems like a
good compromise right
[Applause]